this video was brought to you by Ting
more about them at the end of the video
so you're in need of some quick cash
except you run out of options to make
money legally no one's hiring The
Working Man is a sucker the pay sucks or
whatever other stories you tell yourself
so it looks like we're gonna have to
explore more illicit means of making
money so let's look at our options you
could be a drug dealer drug dealers are
usually viewed as like dirty scumbags
and we don't want to associate ourselves
with them you could commit a myriad of
online fraud yeah although that's
probably the easiest crime to commit
these days and you can do it from home
on a massive scale there's nothing sexy
or exciting about it it doesn't get your
adrenaline pumping what if we robbed the
bank
nobody
okay
hmm now we're talking think about it you
need money banks have a lot of money
compared to other criminals throughout
history bank robbers have always been
seen as the quintessential Robin Hood
stealing from those really rich Bankers
thanks to decades upon Decades of
Hollywood romanticizing bank robbers
every single person has at least thought
about robbing a bank before and besides
today the federal government guarantees
the average person's deposits anyways no
one's gonna get hurt it's victimless
crime we're here for the banks money not
your money your money is insured by the
federal government you're not going to
lose a dime since the general public
isn't directly getting hurt they're much
less likely to retaliate and demand
Justice compared to something like
murderous drug dealers or online
scammers so obviously becoming a career
bank robber is the only logical route
but just like any other crime the
smallest mistake and you are screwed
with a very Hefty fine and prison time
of up to 20 to 25 years depending on if
you assaulted anyone and being that a
little over half of all bank robbers are
eventually caught this new profession of
yours shouldn't be taken lightly out on
top of about the fact that the average
take for bank robberies in 2012 was only
around ten thousand dollars and you'll
see that we have a lot of work to do so
let's learn how to rob a bank
theoretically of course
[Music]
bank robbery is just like any other
business or investment the more risk you
take on typically but not always the
more money you're gonna make that means
there are a few different ways you can
approach robbing said Bank you can go in
guns blazing and force the manager to
open up the Vault you can plan out an
elaborate heist where you go in at night
and break into the Vault and these
methods will typically give you much
more money or you can keep things cool
and calm by simply walking in passing
the teller a demand note telling them to
give you their money and boom you're in
and out without a hinge except you'll
probably only get the money the teller
has in the register which isn't a lot
take Joe Louis case he took the simple
route we just went over by using the man
notes and robbed around 30 banks in 14
months before getting caught 30 Banks
but since he took oribly less risk per
Heist he only ended up with around 250
000 at the end of the day a quarter
million not that much for 30 heist in
the end is not a lot of money it's only
like seven thousand a bank robbery
because in the beginning sometimes I
would only get a thousand for a bank and
one time I we're out of the bank and I
knew I got just nothing from them maybe
a couple thousand and I was so angry I
just walked in the bank next door and
robbed it too even though the police run
away
compare that to the Dunbar robbery case
much more elaborate much more risky but
in just one Heist they left with 18.9
million dollars or 75 times more money
than what Joe Loa did in 30 Heist so
pick your poison but whatever route you
take the number one rule you have to
keep in mind is to not do what's
expected by the public or law
enforcement study the data on what most
would-be bank robbers do on their Heist
and figure out a way to do the exact
opposite to confuse law enforcement for
example the same guy we talked about
earlier Joe Loya figured out that most
rappers do their first High star away
from their home let's say an hour away
then they get super paranoid and
skittish afterwards about being caught
but once they do calm down and are ready
for their second heist they're more
comfortable they get lazy and then
they'll rob a bank that's let's say only
45 minutes away from their home once
they're ready for the third Heist they
choose a bank that's only 30 minutes
away then 20 minutes away and then next
thing you know law enforcement are able
to connect the dots and narrow down
their location until boom prison so what
did Joe Loya do he was in LA so instead
of following the norm he did the exact
opposite of what was expected by robbing
a bank near his home first then going
further and further away from his home
to completely puzzle authorities leading
him all the way to San Diego that is
what you have to do study bank robbery
data recognize the patterns that law
enforcement go after and do the opposite
so now that you have a general idea and
strategy behind bank robberies let's get
into the nitty-gritty details of your
Heist
every great Heist starts with a great
crew right well not so fast
I can't do it sunny
what
I'm not gonna make it sunny partnering
up with other people does have its pros
but it also comes with some major cons
the biggest Pros are you can rob bigger
Banks and take home bigger takes with
multiple people you can instill more
fear into the employees and customers a
very important point that we'll touch on
later since you can bring in people with
different skill sets a dedicated driver
a vault cracker Etc you can do much more
elaborate heists the biggest downside is
that legitimate Partnerships and legal
businesses are already risky enough ask
any successful entrepreneur and they'll
probably have a nightmare of a story to
tell you about a Business Partnership
that went bad but Partnerships in the
criminal underworld where you don't have
the option of suing someone or calling
the police on them that can get pretty
dicey
every person you bring on is not just
another loose end but you have to worry
about their friends and family finding
out on top of that you have to manage
their egos their pride their greed I
told you next time things not ready yet
because I make it ready the point I'm
trying to get at is that if you're gonna
bring on other people onto your new
career path you better trust them with
your life
choosing the right Bank to Rob is pretty
simple but it does depend on what scale
you're going at this with if you're
going in guns blazing you want to find
out what kind of Defense measures they
have in place like Panic buttons bait
money Etc if you're gonna do the whole
breaking in at night and cracking the
vote you're gonna need to choose a bank
that has a security system you can pass
a vault you're able to crack Etc but
whatever Bank you choose for the most
part you're gonna want to make sure that
it has multiple Escape Routes so that
when police arrive they won't know which
direction you took often banks at
freeway interchanges make for Prime
targets
choosing the right getaway car is also
rather simple following our rule of
doing what's unexpected if everyone
envisions the perfect getaway card to be
a van or a tough looking SUV you want to
use the exact opposite maybe a sleeper
car or a Prius something that when law
enforcement arrives and they're scanning
around the area for the potential
getaway car they'll pass right by you
without looking twice
over the years Banks and authorities
have gotten more and more sophisticated
against thieves so just make sure you
don't follow victim to any of these
traps over 75 percent of banks in the
U.S use die packs disguise as cash that
explode shortly after you leave the
building Banks also have cash with GPS
trackers in them then there's a classic
silent alarm on the panic button that
tellers use although these are tricky if
you know where you're doing and are in
and out it shouldn't be too bad when
someone pushes the panic button the
security company the bank uses has to
verify that the alarm is real then relay
it to local PD giving you a small window
to escape as long as you know the button
was pressed you should be fine but don't
stop there because I wouldn't be
surprised if there are other newer
measures banks are using right now
so you have your strategy you maybe have
a crew ready you case your bank you know
the defense measures they might have and
you have a getaway car that flies right
under the radar now it's time for the
get rich quick moment we've been waiting
for if you're doing a covert op it's
going to take a lot more skill a lot
more planning to pull this off going
back to that really big heist where they
made off with 18.9 million dollars maybe
your job will require a man on the
inside like it did for Lum being that
there's practically an infinite amount
of ways to approach this that changes
from bank to bank if you're gonna go
this route you probably know what you're
doing but before you leave maybe do
something like the United California
bank robbery where they made off with
nine million dollars or 55 million
dollars in today's money they cut a hole
in the roof and then cut a hole on the
top of the Vault and even though they
were successful before they left they
jammed the vault door this way when it
was time to open for business the
manager couldn't open the vault and
thought it was probably something with
the locking mechanism itself so they
called in a technician and after hours
of trying to open it he finally
discovered the hole at the top buying
our thieves just a few more hours to
cover their tracks even more pretty
clever move if you're gonna go and join
business hours whether as a lone wolf or
as a crew guns blazing the number one
thing you need to do is to instill fear
into your subjects terrorize them shock
and awe discourage anyone from being a
hero get them to realize that they have
their entire lives ahead of them that
why would they put up a fight against
these vicious robbers just for a few
thousand dollars of the bank's money the
depositors will get their money back
from the government so here you go think
of your family's don't risk your life
don't try and be a hero find clever ways
to conceal your identity wear extra
layers of clothes that you can remove
after the heist creativity is the name
of the game here
once you're in and out boom you just
made some instant easy money but we're
not done yet so Escape in that getaway
car and let's move on to the last step
foreign
so we have all this Heist money that you
just scored good job but before you use
that money you have to make sure it
looks legitimate that you made it
through legal means whether that be a
job business Investments Etc this is
where money laundering comes in which is
another art in its own rights luckily we
already have a video breaking down how
the money launder which will be linked
below this video once you've laundered
your score you're good to go just make
sure that if it's a really big score or
any score for that matter it probably
wouldn't be very wise to make any big
purchases right away another thing to
keep in mind is that everything we
talked about in this video were based on
accounts of people that actually got
caught if you want to make a million
dollars legally in business you should
probably study people who fail to make a
million dollars if you want to rob banks
you should probably study how other
people got caught and find a way around
it this is called negative advice as
time passes on it's going to get harder
and harder to commit any physical crimes
as more and more surveillance comes up
so if this is the career path you want
to take you you better take action right
now theoretically of course
why are learning how to rob banks and
other ways of making money another area
to improve in is learning how to save
more money after all even if you get
really good at robbing banks if you just
blow all that money afterwards you'll be
right back to where you were when you
first started not fun an easy era to
save more money in that most people
Overlook is your phone bill especially
being that most people are stuck at home
or in an office right now and are using
Wi-Fi most of the time this is where
Ting comes in if you're around Wi-Fi a
lot why are you paying so much for a set
monthly data plan with Ting you just pay
for the talk text and data you actually
use each month if you use less you pay
less no contracts no commitments no
prepaid plans either at the end of each
month you're charged for the top tax and
data level of which you reached if you
didn't text one month and only use
things like messenger or Whatsapp you
don't get charged for texting that month
and since tank piggybacks off three
major Nationwide 4G LTE networks almost
all phones already work with team with
the same or even better coverage so
switching over is as simple as signing
up switching your sim card and you're
good to go the average bill hunting is
just 23 dollars a month and if you sign
up today you'll get a 25 service credit
to try to hang out for free for a month
with no strings attached that means you
can keep your existing phone plan open
switch out your sim card to try out Ting
for a month and if you like it and you
find that you'd be paying way less using
your phone the exact same way you've
been using it you can cancel your
existing plan then
see how much you can save and get 25 off
at jake.ting.com with the link below and
support the brands that help make this
channel possible again that's
jake.ting.com with the link below
welcome to the watch of the end Club
this is yet another video that you guys
directly requested in the comments below
so if you have any other recommendations
for future videos that you guys want me
to make you can leave it in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing because there is plenty of
more free video essays just like this
one coming out every single week for
free for your viewing pleasure if you
want some behind the scenes stuff Dan
the life stuff memes Etc you can follow
me on Instagram jaketrain.io that's
gonna wrap it up for this video thank
you so much for watching you've been
awesome I've been Jake I'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]